so the sandman really snuck up on me i
legit forgot it was coming out until the
day it dropped it might also be the best
thing dc has put their name on in years
how's it going everybody i'm red muffler
man and once again i've been dragged out
into the content minds for your
enjoyment today we need to talk about
netflix's dc comics vertigos neil
gaiman's the sandman and
oh boy do i have stuff to say about this
show the first being that i'm actually
surprised the show even exists at all
for those that don't know sandman has a
very
troubled history in terms of adaptations
their attempts to get sandman made into
a movie starting all the way back in
1991 and then every attempt to get it
adapted ended up in production hell for
all intents and purposes sandman seemed
like a cursed property that would never
get a fully realized adaptation but then
here comes netflix hey neil want to make
an adaptation of your beloved 1990s cult
comic sensation oh
yes
yes that sounds lovely excellent i will
now proceed to cancel bone
again
maybe one day
but yeah getting into the show itself
the first thing i want to touch on here
are some of the differences between the
comic and the adaptation and one of the
first things that comes to my attention
was the general scrubbing of most of the
dc mainstays you see sandman originally
was set somewhat heavy-handedly in the
dc universe in fact sandman himself
started as a forgotten dc hero that neil
wanted to reboot but from the get-go one
of the first storylines of sandman
sawdream referencing the existence of
superman and in another immediately
crossing paths with scot-free and
martian manhunter when dream goes to
visit lucifer morningstar in hell in the
comics he's greeted by etriken a demon
synonymous with the dc universe created
by jack kirby but in the adaptation the
demon is just
some dude and for the most part every
crossover element from the original
comics has mostly been scrubbed with the
exception of static shock so yeah this
was a pleasant surprise for me honestly
seeing jed in the last arc of the show
randomly wearing a static shock t-shirt
granted that surprise quickly went to
the wayside once he realized he's being
abandoned by his mother due to parental
custody issues but it's fine cause then
you cut the jet at serial killer con
watching a full episode of static shock
in the hotel room tv so yeah the show
either has no continuity in the greater
dc universe or we live in a hellscape
where the day-to-day lives of these
superheroes have been flanderized and
produced into saturday morning cartoon
shows oh
i love the boys
but yeah jokes aside i'm pretty happy
with this show not having to deal with
any of the continuity garbage in any
other present universe the show gave
neil and the team a chance to really
stretch their legs with what the sandman
is and that extra freedom shows with how
much fun they got to have with this
adaptation and on that topic the sandman
goes to incredible lengths to pay homage
to the original illustrations found in
the books many of the shots are ripped
almost verbatim and recreated in full
live action one great example being
dream once he finally manages to escape
his glass prison and confronts alex he's
almost fully blacked out with the
exception of his ominous glowing white
eyes i saw that and all i could say to
myself was
why why can't sandman's contemporaries
have this kind of stylistic eye it's
honestly a breath of fresh air from the
drab greys and washed out palettes i've
been assaulted with lately from a
good chunk of dc and mcu films sandman
while it tends to keep a lot of its
shots very dark to match the style of
the comic a lot of scenes also tend to
be lit with very bright splashes of
colored light and this adds a lot of
vibrancy to what would normally just be
a dark and muddy mess and it really
helps the show stand apart visually
despite some spotty cgi
all those gargoyles but to my next point
we move on to the sandman goes to hell
and this scene differs pretty hard from
the one we got in the comics the setup
is roughly the same dream is in search
of his helmet and after learning it's
been traded to a demon he journeys to
hell to have an audience with lucifer
morningstar lucifer brings forward the
demon quran's on who has the helmet
dream and coronzon must now do battle in
order to decide who will get the helmet
in the netflix adaptation each side
names a champion dream naming himself
and koronzon naming lucifer to be his
champion cause uh yeah that's fair what
proceeds is a psychic battle where dream
and lucifer are challenging their wits
world views and realities in a grandiose
struggle that sees dream on the brink of
death well pat and oswald cries to the
heavens asking why
only for dream to fight back with the
power of hope winning against lucifer
and taking back the helmet in what i can
only describe as a emotional spectacle
it was super cool oh it was so cool but
then you have the comic which sees
korrons on not being a little [ __ ] and
actually fighting his own battles but we
don't get a big emotional fight with big
epic music no no no no no no it's
actually an improv stage show the entire
scene is really playful chronzone
appears with a suit and the two start
throwing reality bending soliloquy
towards one another in front of a live
studio audience i'd expect this type of
at a burlesque show not hell and then to
top it all off dream is just casually
dropping bars dressed up like a blues
brother and he is demolishing this demon
jobber without a second thought there's
no struggle this dude is just dying if
anything i'm actually kind of sad we
didn't get this version of the scene it
shows off dream in a more playful light
where even if he's deadpan you can tell
he's still very quirky and it's kind of
a shame granted we still get to see a
big part of him being a a quirky little
dork i love dream he's
he's a huge dork but then we have what i
think is the best part of sandman and
that is john d the antagonist of the
first arc and for those that don't know
john in the comics initially started off
as a super villain named dr destiny hey
yo that name goes kinda hard though he'd
come into possession of dreams ruby
after dream was forcefully abducted and
proceeded to you said ruby to wreak
absolute havoc on the planet but the
more he used the ruby the more it wore
down on his sanity eventually he ended
up being confined to arkham asylum
however he escapes and using the ruby
once again wreaks havoc until he's
finally put away by the combined efforts
of dream and the jla in the comic john d
comes off as someone who may have been
good at one point but has lost all
meaning in pretty much anything that
they do because they're uh
crazy
john in the show however has a certain
warmth it shows in almost every aspect
of his character from his mother
sacrificing her life to make sure that
he's safe as he's crying over her dead
body
begging her to stop jon
warning his victims
not to attack him
lest they hurt themselves
you can tell by speaking with john that
he's not well
but
he still shows a shred of humanity no
matter how dark his actions may be
and the best example i feel is comparing
how he handles rosemary in the comics
versus the show for those that don't
know rosemary was the person that
happened to pick up john while he was
hitchhiking back to his house and uh
very unfortunate for her rosemary in the
comics remains oblivious to jon's true
nature throughout her driving him around
she speaks with john who vents to her
about his problems and the two seem to
get close to one another then once they
arrive jon just
casually shoots rosemary and takes the
ruby of dream any sort of remorse was
left at the door a long long time ago
but then we get the same scene in the
show rosemary knows that jon is not well
she's seen him kill someone and for all
intents and purposes she's jon's hostage
she drives john to his old house for him
to pick up the ruby
just like in the comic
at this point i fully expected john to
blow her brains out and move on being
this full-on unforgivable villain he
tells her that good people tend to not
be able to protect themselves and
he gives her the amulet of protection
that his mother gave to him to make sure
that the person who helped him despite
fearing for her life was going to live
the rest of her life in safety this
trend continues in the episode 24 7. in
the comics jon uses the ruby to
manipulate people at a local diner
making their lives hell for no other
reason other than it's just something
entertaining for him but in the show
jon has this childlike obsession
with the truth he wants to live in a
world where lies are something that
simply do not exist and everyone can
truly connect with one another jon
idolizes this perfect place where people
don't have to suffer the deceit that he
had to go through that ruined his entire
life and while this leads the tragic
slaughter of the people in the diner
jon was coming from a place of wanting
to do what he felt was right he wants to
live in a world of truth even if that
truth is ugly even if that truth hurts
people and that childlike obsession
makes him a far more interesting villain
than his original appearance in the
comics
it feels
grounded sincere and i think that's why
i like the sandman as much as i do this
is a quote in the final episode that
perfectly encapsulates my feelings on
this show humanity is far more vivid to
us
than any marvels of power sometimes to
tell a compelling story it's not about
displaying incredible feats of strength
or power it's not about how good your
cgi gargoyles are how clean your
penciling is in a comic or how much
budget you have for special effects
sometimes it's enough to sit down and
tell the story of what it means to be a
human to put pen to paper and let those
sincere thoughts out and
that's all i have to say about sandman
it's great i can't recommend it enough
please watch it and feel free to drop
your thoughts on the sandman in the
comments below i want to thank rob once
again for letting me gush about this
cool little show and if you like what we
do feel free to drop a like and
subscribe and if you like me i'm on
twitch twitter and youtube at red
muffler mad and uh yeah have a good one
everybody take it easy